hello everyone and welcome back to the
show that today gets somehow even
handsomer than your host mark ellis it's
also gonna get funnier and more charming
and i'd say in all likelihood better
smelling because we got an all-time
great match-up on our hands right now on
versus it's a hoot nanny harboring
hollywood's hottest hunks brad pitt and
george clooney you heard it right the
two a-listers who've combined to win
four people's sexiest man of the year
awards are now duking it out for career
bragging rights on the show that's been
described as fast-paced witty and as
entertaining as it is star-studded and
coolly stylish
oh wait that was just the critics
consensus for ocean's eleven but that
stars george and brad and like 38 other
famous people and a cameo by either me
or topher grace go back watch the movie
and you'll figure it out
really
in one corner we have brad pitt one of
the greatest movie stars of all time who
you love from clicks like fight club
moneyball and once upon a time in
hollywood he also produces big time
movies and i hear he's in pretty good
shape in the other corner it's george
clooney whom you may adore from movies
like out of sight michael clayton and
the descendants he also directs big time
movies and i have it on good authority
that he is an actual doctor or played
one on tv but i'd still trust him to
give me a physical
and i've said too much here's how we'll
determine a winner round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three iconic moments round
four zest fully clean and then we'll do
a wild card round that could involve any
of the many tricks in the respective
bags of brad and george they star in
movies produce direct them and somehow
still find the time to represent
charities sell adult beverages and
appear on the covers of countless
magazines they're busy fellas so i'll
forgive them for not showing up here
today it's water under the bridge boys
oh and did i mention that they both have
won the highest prize tinseltown has to
offer you heard me right in fact these
leading men have combined to win five
mtv movie awards mr smith is going
head-to-head against mr fox and the
winner will be granted exclusive access
to my spec script for ocean's 14 where
we take buffalo bills in prim nevada for
every cent it's worth let's get it on
round one box office it's fun to be a tv
star like clooney was and i imagine it's
a pretty sweet gig to be a perfectly abd
stud in thelma louise but once these
fellas started earning starring roles in
feature films we all came out to bear
witness yes brad and george have padded
their blockbuster resume with lots of
art house indies and oscar darlings but
it's all added up to some seriously
boffo box office for the bros for george
clooney his top five grossing films of
all time have been a mixed bag of
starring roles and ensemble pieces most
of which involve large bodies of water
the ocean's trilogy represents three of
his five biggest movie theater takeovers
and they combine for over 1.1 billion
dollars but g cloon no one's ever called
him that and with good reason wasn't
done with his aquatic references his
fourth highest grossing flick ever is
the perfect storm which sailed to 328
million dollars and gave us an all-time
great money shot in the trailer as for
cloondog i'll find a good nickname for
him at some point his biggest
blockbuster ever we go to gravity the
sandra bullock starring either cousins
or siblings or something of that ocean
franchise space drama that took in 688
million bucks here on planet earth in
space no one can hear you scream but on
this planet i can listen to your cries
that george wasn't even in that movie
for that long and tis a fair point but
get this brad pitt's highest grossing
movie ever is
no it's not the baseball one it's not
the vampire or the zombie one it's not
even any of them ocean flicks it's
deadpool 2 and he's in it for like .4
seconds which is barely enough time to
get a shot off in the nba so i won't
give him full credit for that 700
million dollar plus total but still dude
was only in it for a parsec and we all
recognized him brad also has world war z
mr and mrs smith and troy checking in
with more coin than the oceans films wwz
made 536 million dollars with smith and
troy both notching above 480 million and
how's this for a diverse array of smash
hits movies like inglorious bastards
megamind once upon a time in hollywood
seven and the curious case of benny
buttons all grossed over 300 million
dollars wow we will see this guy in
anything like the time i paid full price
to see meet joe black just so i could
see the first trailer for star wars
episode 1 the phantom menace on the big
screen and i'm convinced at least half
of that movie's 44 million dollar total
take was thanks to nerds like me wanting
to see some galaxy far far away wait
you're telling me the horn guys
lightsaber ignites in both directions
one for me joe black please when i
introduce you
if i say who you are
i don't think anyone will stay for
dinner
then don't
i also paid to see from dusk till dawn
several times because it slaps as the
kids say and i would argue it's the
superior vampire movie more on that
later how'd it do back in 1996
only 25 million dollars huh luckily gc
stuck with this hollywood thing and
cranked out hits like the descendants at
175 million dollars tomorrowland at 206
million and batman and robin at 238
million dollars say what you want but
it's arguably the fifth best batman film
of the 90s this is why superman works
alone the two dear friends teamed up for
burn after reading which scorched the
multiplex for a total of 168 million
bucks but from there we get a slew more
brad pitt mentions 12 monkeys chimped
its way to 168 million dollars as well
12 years a slave made 180 million
dollars and fury an interview with the
vampire not a vampire the vampire both
crews to well over 200 million bones
okay so they're both as bankable and as
reliable as movie stars get with
possibly a wider array of genres than
any other two a-listers but as of now
brad pitt can claim the higher total box
office numeral making eight point five
four billion dollars worth of cash
register jingles gloony oh i like that
we're keeping that one flicks i've raked
in an even 5 billion dollars making for
a per movie average of 140 million can
his good bud brad topple that well last
time i checked 186 million is the higher
of the two numbers and coincidentally
that happens to be his exact per
cinematic experience average it's been a
good slugfest in this opening round of
verses but after trading body blows for
the last three decades brad pitt emerges
as the box office king over prince
george and mr cool world wins round one
even though cool world did like 14
million dollars total which is somehow
still two million dollars more than true
romance
okay we're gonna talk about this in the
next round round two tomato meter slash
audience score yes now the critics and
audiences will have their say and i'll
save you all the suspense true romance
is at 93 percent eking its way past cool
world's four percent hey if roger rabbit
hadn't come along a few years prior we
all still might own vhs copies of cool
world
[Music]
brad and george have been able to
maintain their career apexes for dozens
of years not just because they're
handsome but because they make quality
entertainment time and time again but
who's freshest in the veggie patch let's
take a look brad pitt produced and acted
in his two freshest films 12 years a
slave at 95 percent and moneyball at 94
percent he's also gotten glorious
bastards at 89 percent 12 monkeys at 88
percent and once upon a time in
hollywood at 85 percent george clooney
who i must point out at this juncture
was in a movie that actually involved a
real tomato bleeds fresh v8 as well once
again gravity is his top dog this time
on the tomato meter with a 96 percent
followed by three kings at 94 percent
and a trio of flicks at 93 percent the
fantastic mr fox out of sight and good
night and good luck which he also
directed
anne wrote and i think produced does
this guy take naps as far as big time
misses for these two fellas brad has
less high profile ones but beyond the c
was also produced by him and it only
mustered at 34
the devil's own despite starring
harrison ford and featuring fun
questionable irish accents rest down
below at 35 percent
i'm in a band i don't have time to
explain i'll just i get my gear not
clear right then we arrive at mr clooney
the good news for all you batman fans is
that batman and robin is not his lowest
of all time in the tomato meter and that
might be the only silver lining for that
movie it's a 12 percent but i can't
stress this enough it has nothing to do
with mr freeze's puns keep doing your
thing arnold
all right everyone
chill clooney's lowest ever on the
tomato meter is super ironic because
it's the actual movie that does star a
certain vegetable return of the killer
tomatoes released in 1988
is at zero percent come on look who
cares about tomatoes but come on it was
the 80s and george probably needed some
coin i didn't give bradford credit for
deadpool 2's box office glory so i'm
also not going to penalize george for
taking a role that was basically between
the facts of life and er tv gigs
speaking of er currently has an 84
audience score facts of life doesn't
have a tomato meter consensus but you
know where it is 100
right in here good bad you take them
both and there you have the movies of
brad and george all told the fellows are
very close when it comes to their per
film average on the tomato meter brad
pitt is at 65 percent bested by george's
67
so now we'll look at the audience score
side of things it's pretty close here
too for pitt fight club seven and snatch
climb all the way up the metric into the
90s clooney isn't quite as big with the
audiences but oh brother where arthel
still manages an 89
fantastic mr fox is at 85 percent and
george also has a cameo as you guessed
it a doctor and south park bigger longer
and uncut and that kenny's its way to an
88 audience score and now the bad news
for cape crusader adores batman and
robin is the low bar for clooney on the
audience score resting at 16
return of the killer tomatoes however
rebounds mightily and gets all the way
to 49
do i smell a sequel in the works brad
and george could produce it george could
direct it it'd be free publicity for us
everyone wins speaking of directorial
efforts george's best flick on the
tomato meter would be good night and
good luck at 93 percent but he also has
the odds of march at 84 percent and
confessions of a dangerous mind at 79
sadly for all involved the monuments men
which should have been great everything
was right there fell flat and landed at
30 on the tomato meter georgia's
directing average per film on the tm is
just south of fresh at 58
but i have the confidence that that's
gonna get to fresh once our new the
killer tomatoes awaken movie comes out
both fellas have adjudicated themselves
fabulously despite some early career
choices coming back to haunt them but
because he's got a slight advantage on
the tomato meter with some help from the
movies he directed i'm gonna lean ever
so slightly in george's direction looney
g gets the point and we're tied at one a
piece round three iconic moments when
you have icons like a george clooney or
a brad pitt you need an equally iconic
host to run down all the many memorable
moments they've provided us over the
years but apparently chuck barris was
busy hosting the gong show so you got me
and for clooney it always seems that his
best scenes and sequences are derived
from his ability to speak to another
character in a way that's part
empathetic part condescending all
charisma dude can fire you hire you or
ask for your help like he's the
smoothest guy on the planet even when he
may technically be hovering above the
planet at that particular time for brad
pitt there's no glossy way to say this
dude eats on camera better than anyone
sends that kid from the pie eating
contest and stand by me in the oceans
films he's crushing fancy vegas buffet
fair like shrimp cocktails in moneyball
he prefers junk food like twinkies and
once upon a time in hollywood he's
chugging late 1960s brewski's and to our
loyal viewers out there
that diet is not going to make you look
like brad pitt believe me i've tried as
recently as this morning and probably
later on this evening george clooney's
big screen presence was evident even on
nbc's must-see tv thursday night lineup
but for me that promise was validated
with his sinful leader in from dusk till
dawn it would be the first in a line of
con artist types that we would never
root for in real life but that george is
just so damn charming even harvey keitel
and his kid was kind of like george and
clooney kidnapped them and took them to
a vampire lair disguised as a crazed
biker bar
sweet necktat as well the rest of the
world probably found out how schwab
clooney could be when he starred in out
of sight and from that moment on j-wo
and g-quo would be household names
forevermore the most iconic scene in
that one film is up for debate but the
ride those two hotties taking a car
trunk together is way up there can i
also shout out the peacemaker not the
show it's really not the best movie ever
but i do love when he's dangling on top
of what could be a bomb as he's holding
onto a rope tied to a bridge for dear
life it's fun stuff before brad pitt
became iconic his midsection was already
laying the groundwork thelma louise
showcased him as a sexy rogue cowboy
true romance saw him as a stoner roomie
with almost nothing going on but it
wasn't until seven that we saw some real
iconic moments i know i know legends of
the fall has some wondrous hero shots
and a river runs through it features fly
fishing with my close personal friend
tom skerritt but then seven hid and it
was like wow this guy can keep up with
morgan freeman matching wits with a
fella who voices god and a penguin soo
sayer ain't easy but check out his
absolute breakdown when he discovers
what's in the box hint it's not a goop
product well i mean from a certain point
of view
what's in the box
what's in the [ __ ] box bumbling
brother evid in oh brother where art
thou kicked off a string of successful
clooney turns in coen brothers movies
and that trend would continue to rave
reviews in flicks like hale caesar and
burn after reading a movie where the
scene steeler was brad pitt he plays
possibly the dimmest personal trainer on
earth but it's a hilarious turn that
holds up after repeat viewings while
we're on the subject of collabing how
about that oceans trilogy 12 and 13 may
not have been as memorable but that's
only because the first ocean's 11 was
such a rollicking good time clooney is
danny ocean convincing matt damon to
join the gang brad pitt in goofy
disguises while getting his car bloating
done is a hoot but both fellas can get
serious when they need to clooney has
some yucks above raging emotional waters
in the descendants and his slick talking
fireer and up in the air is as inspiring
for travelers as it is for folks
thinking about settling down one day
maybe who knows
all right i'm blushing a little bit i
like that movie a lot but for me clooney
in movies like michael clayton and
siriana is next level he's just so
focused in different ways trying to work
through the growing madness inside tom
wilkinson in clayton then you have a
much pudgier george taking center stage
in syriana similarly brad pitt can have
a good time while going through
competitive anguish in moneyball and his
meeting with the baseball scouts is an
all-timer
an underrated asset for pitt is his
ability to fully disappear into roles
despite the fact that he's arguably the
biggest a-lister on this planet sure
he's had his hero moments in epics like
troy and next level fun and chemistry
with angelina jolie and mr and mrs smith
but he was also benjamin button and a
vampire and lieutenant aldo rain in in
glorious bastards he's a refreshing
breath of american machismo as he owns
the camera in every scene in that movie
in the same way that you can't take your
eyes off of him in another tarantino
film you know the one that took place
once upon a time in parts of the valley
fair enough it's such a tough call
between the two up in the air has to
find my life goals as a comedian who
frequently travels on the road i love
hotel living and i'm obsessed with
finding the best airport bar in every
terminal i highly recommend chili's 2 in
terminal c in chicago but pitt and 12
monkeys changed my entire outlook on
what a movie star could do and then the
mic drop iconic moment tyler durden in
fight club
hit me in the ear the rules about fight
club speech the meeting on an airplane
the reveal ish of who the hell this
spectre really was it's a fascinating
exploration brought to life by pitt's
performance clooney was down for a scrap
in this round but you don't talk about
the club brad pitt eeks out a victory in
this round and goes up 2-1 round four
zestfully clean all right mark we get it
they're super famous movie stars
generational talents men of such
charismatic confidence that i feel like
i could successfully knock off a few
vegas casinos if any of my other 10
friends would call me back but that's
all on the screen this round is zest
fully clean because it's going to
examine what else they've been up to
selling soap is what it's called but we
have everything from awards to charities
two pitching beverages considered in
this round and wow do these boys have a
resume that comes with that as i hinted
at the top of the show both gentlemen
have received the highest honor that
people magazine can bestow they've each
won sexiest blake shelton of the year
twice pitt in 1995 and 2000 clooney in
97 and 2006
wait didn't siriana come out like the
year before so you're telling me the guy
gains 35 pounds in pure donuts and beer
then loses it in time to be the sexiest
guy on earth again
this look i'm just a different species i
humbly bow before thee both fellas have
an oscar on the shelf two actually each
one has a statue for best supporting
actor and one for producing so now let's
start diving into what we're really here
to discuss who sells alcohol better brad
pitt got paid a reported four million
dollars to pitch heineken in a super
bowl ad but george clooney and his buddy
randy gerber better known as mr cindy
crawford congrats created the cos amigos
tequila brand which has sold even better
than rocker turned tequila ceo sammy
hagar's cabo wabo brand they've moved
over a million cases and on top of that
if you're drinking too hard the night
before you might want some caffeine to
perk you up the next day don't worry
george has you covered there too he's
made an estimated 40 million dollars
representing nespresso and in 2021 guess
who else started doing coffee ads you
guessed it benjamin button hey are you
an old baby who needs a pick-me-up in
the middle afternoon after you're
starting to age backwards coffee both
are also heavily involved in charities
and they teamed up to raise millions of
dollars to combat humanitarian crises in
the darfur region of the sudan under the
banner not on my watch and while clooney
got a few big breaks on tv before he was
a movie star pitt has popped onto the
small screen since he became an a-lister
to the delight of many a studio audience
most notably when he jumped onto the set
of friends typical of you rachel green
queen rachel does whatever she wants in
a little rachel land
[Laughter]
and here's what's really fun they both
also run production companies pit with
plan b and clooney with smokehouse and
sometimes those two companies will get
in bidding wars over the rights to a
sought after project brad pitt went out
for moneyball clooney was the victor
when argo was at stake then pitt gained
a measure of revenge after he clinched
the big short and now a new thriller
starring pitt and clooney sparked its
own rights battle with apple tv
reportedly winning but through it all if
you're looking at who's done more off
camera you can't go wrong with either
however casamigos sold for an estimated
1 billion dollars that's too much to
ignore unless i get on scrooge mcduck's
bad side and in a round all about
salesmanship i gotta go with george
clooney gloony gets the round and we're
tied once again two to two and now it's
time for the wild card round wow what a
difference okay admitted you didn't
think that a versus episode between brad
pitt and george clooney would be decided
in bend oregon but here we are the last
existing blockbuster video is in that
very town but back when these fellows
became movie stars you had a blockbuster
on every street corner a hollywood video
in every village and in my hometown of
colonial williamsburg we had video
update
two of them so it's gonna be a battle of
six sections to win the war your classic
video stores genres of horror action
comedy sci-fi drama and family films to
win this round and thus the match who
has the better flick in each corner of
blockbuster which actor can lay claim to
the best in a particular realm of
classification let's get things going
with our first category wait wait wait
did we rewind best instinct my mom's
gonna kill me if she gets charged two
dollars again kicking off with horror
and as much buzz his interview with a
vampire received when it was released it
never really did that much for me the
trio of brad tom cruise and christian
slater was exciting to see and it was a
true breakout performance for a young
kirsten dunst but if we're talking
vampire movies i gotta set the bar with
from dusk till dawn oh wait what's that
i hear something could it be a horde of
zombies piling on top of each other to
climb a massive wall in world war z you
know say you want about undead walkers
but they put a premium on working
together solid teammates if it was too
close to call between wwz and fdtd then
we'll let them debate the silver medal
rights later the gold has to go to seven
in the horror section and we head over
to sci-fi brad pitt could go up two to
nothing here as he has an ace in the
hole with terry gilliam's 12 monkeys
clooney can counter with gravity the
undercard here i suppose would be
solaris taking on ad astra but as far as
the heavyweight division is concerned
gravity has the tomato meter and box
office advantage with room to spare and
although 12 monkeys was much more
ambitious and daring gravity stuck the
landing a little better even if poor
george wasn't necessarily around to
witness it clooney gets the point and
we're tied one to one and now we head
over to action movies these fellas have
combined to make at least a baker's
dozen of quality action films from spy
thrillers like the american or spy game
to the zany comedic injection of flicks
like the lost city all the way to war
thievery with three kings but george
clooney officially became a movie star
after out of sight so we'll let that
flick go up against the brad pitt
actioner that starred someone else
important in his life angelina jolie
with mr and mrs smith both actioners are
fun rides that rely on the romantic
chemistry of the two leads to keep us
enthralled so i'll make a snap decision
and roll with
out of sight because it came along first
and also features michael keaton who's
as good of a tiebreaker as it gets next
up is comedy and here's where clooney's
history with the coen brothers will pay
dividends brad and george were wonderful
when burn after reading but that movie
will be pitt's submission clooney also
has oh brother where art thou and i find
that to be far superior to both hale
caesar and burn after reading g-clue
gets the point and now goes up 3-1
luckily brad pitt has a few family
movies to get him back in the ball game
george clooney was fantastic in that fox
movie about the mr but brad has sinbad
which is you know and he has happy feet
too
which i mean penguins but he'll take the
round on the strength of megamind he's
the hero of heroes in that family
animated feature with a great soundtrack
and now he can tie the lead of george if
he's able to score big in dramas which
is the most tightly contested of all
these categories these two gentlemen
know how to cook up a great performance
in a riveting story and you know that's
the case because winners like good night
and good luck moneyball confessions of a
dangerous mind and ingorious bastards
will just be sitting on the bench here
going for the glory is going to be fight
club for brad pitt and up in the air for
george what a tough call for me up in
the air is how i patterned my actual
life but sometimes i wish i had a club
where we do stuff that's not talked
about i gotta give the slight edge to
fight club simply because it took us
through so many twists and turns and
head trips even as the story itself
never loses momentum so we're tied at
three apiece meaning we go to the
tiebreaker within the tiebreaker round
kind of like double secret probation and
we'll head to that final section that
you know quentin tarantino took way too
seriously when he worked at hollywood
video staff picks yep those off the wall
favorites selected by your video store
employees to wow customers what would
they be for george and brad i'd say it's
michael clayton for clooney and the
assassination of jesse james by the
coward robert ford for pitt and i just
said a lot of names staff picks are good
to impress your friends with is cinema
but the performances and story gotta
hold up that's certainly the case with
both of these gems but for a complete
movie experience
i feel like michael clayton wins out
because it's well-acted and isn't you
know one of the slowest movies ever i'm
riveted by the jesse james movie but at
some point i am going to take a nap wake
up and we'll still be talking about
killing that guy from the old west so
clooney wins the staff picks and thus
the blockbuster round and thus the match
in one of the closest episodes in show
and all of sports history george clooney
has defeated brad pitt three to two wow
i really didn't see it going this way
and i write the show i felt like brad
had the upper hand the whole match but
he couldn't quite close the deal against
his good buddy george however this is
all just my opinion and i didn't even
work at video update i applied multiple
times but never got the green light so
instead i forged a summer job career at
mini golf america instead where i owned
the course record for like a night hit
me up on social media with your opinion
and defend your choice with vigor i'm at
mark ellison your question brad or
george they're both beloved by all of us
here at rotten tomatoes so stay tuned
for all the latest in movies tv and
actors who eat food in every scene
they're in thanks for watching versus
i'm your host mark ellis and as always
this show is the reverse moneyball quote
there's all the other shows and then 50
feet of crap and then us
i probably should have just said you're
either in or you're out right now
you